on va revenir sur cette affaire qui
intrigué beaucoup de monde cet été
l'acteur Marouane béréni connu pour son
rôle d'Abdel dans la série Plus belle la
vie a disparu des radars le 3 août
dernier la nuit ça disparition le
véhicule qu'il y appartient à percuter
une femme de 38 ans et son chien près
d'un camping à Mâcon l'enquête laisse
donc à penser qu'elle était conduite par
l'acteur qui est toujours introuvable
vous allez voir la victime sort du
silence aujourd'hui
Sandra elle elle nous a donné
un premier témoignage je vous le dis et
c'est incroyable ce qu'elle nous dit
Gilles cette histoire est complètement
folle d'abord écoutez puisqu'elle
raconte vous allez voir Michel Marie va
nous le raconter mais Sandra raconte
dans le début de son témoignage raconte
l'accident dont elle a été victime début
août ce qui s'est passé vraiment est
horrible vous allez voir ça fait froid
dans le dos et donc on cherche toujours
Abdel donc de la série Plus Belle La Vie
qui est introuvable depuis le 3 août
dernier écoutez
un message piéton qui se trouve un peu
plus au dessus de la boîte de nuit les
phares se sont allumées et il a accéléré
et en fait l'au-delà je me suis dit il
m'a peut-être vu il a peut-être
m'esquiver et j'ai pas eu le temps de
réagir qui m'a rentré dedans et j'étais
propulsé futur maître avant même que
d'après les témoins il m'est rouler
dessus parce que j'avais la trace d'un
pneu sur ma cuisse et puis j'ai la
hanche le 25 gauche qui est fracturé
donc en plus de ça il m'a roulé de super
dessus
alors merci Michel Marie d'être avec
nous encore ce soir vous allez voir ce
qu'elle nous raconte son bras cette
histoire est complètement folle
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
effectivement une histoire complètement
folle ça se déroule le dans la nuit du
du 3 ou 4 août de cet été là dernier 23h
Sandra qui vient de parler est avec son
chien elle traverse sur les passages
cloutés et on est à au nord de Mâcon
devant une boîte de nuit qui s'appelle
le club 400 elle ne sort pas de la boîte
elle promenait son chien et là un gros
4x4 de marque Mercedes
fonce sur elle elle l'a vu arriver
le 4x4 la renverse roule sur sur cette
femme et ne s'arrête pas
le 4x4 sera retrouvé le lendemain ou le
surlendemain dans un petit village qui
s'appelle Fuissé c'est à quelques
kilomètres de Mâcon alors
l'acteur Marouane béréni n'est pas le
propriétaire en titre de la carte grise
de ce véhicule en revanche il avait
l'habitude a priori de d'utiliser ce
véhicule et on pense les policiers en
tout cas pensent très sérieusement que
c'est lui qui était au volant de ce
véhicule parce qu'ils ont retrouvé un
certain mode alors justement à la suite
de l'accident tout le monde l'informe
que le conducteur du véhicule pourrait
être un acteur qui joue dans Plus belle
la vie donc Marouane Berrini écouté sa
réaction comment elle l'a pris
et quand j'étais à l'hôpital parce que
j'ai passé cinq jours en réanimation
mais j'ai eu le GSL qui m'a contacté en
me disant que il y a une probabilité
pour qu'on ait trouvé la personne et on
a sorti un article c'est là où j'ai vu
l'article et j'ai fait ah d'accord je le
connaissais pas j'étais encore loin de
m'imaginer qu'il y avait quelqu'un de
connu qui habite dans la région
oui alors précisons quand même que dans
la série c'est Abdel 14 ans il a 34 ans
et ça fait 14 ans qu'il est quelque
chose qu'il avait 14 ans dans la série
là il a 34 ans 14 ans dans la série
c'est un des personnages principaux
c'est important de le dire d'ailleurs il
était très important à la fin de ce qui
s'est diffusé là puisqu'il changeait de
vie il revenait il était avocat il
revenait avec une femme pour élever leur
enfant donc la nouvelle série qui va se
tourner bientôt devait en faire un
personnage essentiel ils ont dû tout
changer ils ont dû tout changer ça
démarre le tournage le 23 octobre et il
ne sera pas dans les premiers épisodes
la suite on verra alors alex je voulais
dire oui je veux juste dire quelque
chose parce que bon je connaissais pas
Marouane seulement mais son agent et mon
agent j'ai beaucoup d'amis dans Plus
belle la vie aujourd'hui le problème
c'est que vous avez plein de gens qui
sont tous très très mal voilà alors il y
a cette victime bien sûr vous allez voir
le témoignage le problème c'est que elle
l'a dit elle-même d'ailleurs dans ce que
vous écoutez les phares étaient allumés
il a foncé vers moi personne ne sait
c'est lui conduisait cette voiture ne
lui appartenait pas personne ne sait
s'il y avait pas un complice maintenant
on dit qu'il y a peut-être quelqu'un
dans la voiture cet homme qui vivait une
année absolument horrible c'était les 10
ans de la mort de son frère
zooplanet qui était un ancien artiste
qui était mort il y a 10 ans assassiné
terrible pour sa famille une année très
dure il a même posté sur les réseaux
sociaux plein d'hommages à son frère
dans cette année-là il se Plus belle la
vie s'était arrêté donc c'était une
année où c'est très complexe il allait
pas bien déjà donc il se passe ce truc
s'il n'est pas coupable
et si s'il est parti il ne va jamais
revenir je vais pas reprendre des
histoires comme l'affaire d'Outreau ou
des choses horribles comme ça on
accusait des gens à tort ce que j'ai
juste c'est que pour l'instant personne
ne sait rien et que c'est très dur et
que si cet homme est encore vivant ce
que tout le monde souhaite parce que si
il est vivant tout le monde est là à
dire il faut qu'il se rende il faut pas
qu'ils se rende il faut qu'il
réapparaisse et là il sera jugé et on
verra cet élu et pour l'instant
si tu veux c'est un drame aussi pour
toute sa famille et pour tous ces amis
je trouve c'est dur de dire c'est lui
c'est lui les personnes dit c'est lui
c'est lui d'accord les enquêteurs
souhaitent l'entendre comme témoin voilà
témoin juste témoin mais il a disparu
alors il a disparu et il se trouve que
le véhicule a été retrouvé dans un
village à 20 km de l'accident là où il a
une maison voilà et donc il y a des
indices qui laissent à penser aux
enquêteurs
qu'il était dans le véhicule voilà mais
on n'en sait pas plus et c'est
volatilité cette histoire parce que elle
explique ensuite aussi comment les
forces de l'ordre se sont orientées vers
la piste de Marouane béréni donc
l'acteur de Plus belle la vie c'est vrai
que c'est un truc de fou ça s'est passé
en août personne ne l'a retrouvé
personne ne sait où il est c'est fou
au niveau de la plaque d'immatriculation
les caméras de vidéosurveillance étaient
présentes aussi sur les lieux donc je
pense qu'ils ont dû avoir affaire à tout
ça et puis après vous trouvant nos
véhicules ils ont une immatriculation et
puis avec la voiture le choc qui
représentait à la vente et c'est pour ça
qu'il y a des prélèvements à cette heure
qui sont faits au niveau ADN au niveau
de mes vêtements et du pare-choc avant
de la voiture alors tous les acteurs
Plus Belle La Vie existent que ils sont
dans l'incompréhension totale disent que
c'est un garçon adorable sans problème
parce qu'à un moment donné ils se sont
dit parce qu'au début le téléphone ne
répondait pas puis après ils sont dit
tiens il a une un message et ils
essayent de dire si tu captes un message
qu'on envoie quelque part viens même on
va t'aider parce que tous ces amis et
toute cette famille lui dit juste
réapparaît et on t'aidera mais il était
en situation psychologique tellement
complexe que voilà aujourd'hui des infos
qu'on a Michel
les policiers apparemment disent que
c'était sa voiture il a été confondu
avec la plaque d'immatriculation mais on
sait pas s'il était dedans alors et un
bras long avec la voiture
la voiture ne la carte grise n'a pas été
c'est pas sa voiture en termes la carte
grise n'a pas été fait oui mais en
revanche c'est le véhicule qui
l'utilisait c'est le véhicule dans
lequel on retrouve son ADN à l'intérieur
ces empreintes digitales saison sont son
empreinte génétique et ça ça peut pas
dire qu'il était au volant exactement
est-ce que la caméra de vidéo sur les
images de ça ne veut pas dire ça ne veut
pas dire que c'est lui qui conduisait
maintenant ce qui est quand même très
étonnant cette histoire c'est qu'à
partir du moment où il y a cet accident
et il disparaît
une bonne raison de le faire ce que je
veux te dire c'est que même si il était
passager il était tellement en situation
délicate peut-être que j'ai une
infection peut-être qu'il avait bu cette
soirée qu'il avait
c'est pas très grave
c'est quelqu'un tu assumes tu te sauves
pas tu disparais pas alors disparaît pas
justement mais on est d'accord soit lui
c'est ça même si c'est pas lui il se
présente dans tous les cas de figure
c'est quelqu'un qui est jeune
il faut qu'il pense à l'ensemble des
choses c'est-à-dire à cette victime à sa
vie va pas rester dans les rangs comme
ça
avec le décès du petit du premier je
comprends pas la vraie vie c'est Sandra
et bien sûr justement du jour du
lendemain de l'accident il disparaît et
puis en même temps je vous rappelle
quand même qu'en 2022 il avait problème
il s'est retrouvé en garde à vue parce
qu'il était complètement bourré et qui
s'effrité avec les gens
toxicomanie
l'après victime c'est Sandra ouais je
voudrais vraiment qu'on reste sur l'idée
que la victime c'est Sandra alors
justement depuis l'accident Sandra elle
tente de loin de l'acteur par tous les
moyens y compris les réseaux sociaux son
objectif qu'il se rende écouter
en supposant que ça soit lui ce que je
garde le côté de présomption mais je me
dis dans le cas ou si ça pouvait être
lui si je pouvais l'aider en tant que
victime total à faire prendre conscience
même si c'était pas lui que il avait
prêté sa voiture et qui protégeait
qu'elle aura qu'importe moi je me dis
moi je suis pas responsable de quelque
chose dans l'idéal je manifeste je dois
prendre le risque de tout perdre je vois
qu'aujourd'hui il y a pas eu de réponse
qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait elle lui écrit
un mot elle lui a dit
s'il te plaît je suis la personne qui a
été renversée avec mon chien j'ai besoin
de réponse pour me permettre de me
rétablir et d'avancer rends-toi à la
police pour qu'il puisse t'entendre sur
les faits si c'est vraiment pas toi
pourquoi ne pas donner signe de vie
depuis ce jour ce jeudi 3 août à 23h où
ma vie a totalement basculé je t'en prie
c'est moi la victime qui te le demande
rends-toi pour avoir le fin mot de cette
histoire et que si c'est pas toi que la
police puisse s'orienter vers une autre
direction s'il en existe une autre ce
qui m'étonnerait sinon depuis plus d'une
semaine j'aurai eu des nouvelles merci
alors elle a essayé de prendre contact
avec elle Gilles elle est avec lui elle
est exemplaire très franchement elle dit
à supposer que ce soit toi elle a fait
quand même hôpital elle est brisée
centre de rééducation donc elle lui
donne on va rappeler c'est les séquelles
alors elle a eu côte cassée fracture du
bassin notamment plusieurs jours
d'hôpital et puis un centre de
rééducation et pour se reconstruire
physiquement et 5 jours de réanimation 5
jours elle a besoin de savoir ce qui
s'est passé c'est pour ça et tout le
monde lance un appel pour qu'il se
présente le problème c'est il est
extrêmement fragile psychologiquement
est-il en état de se présenter a-t-il
alors moi la vraie question aussi que je
pose chez Marie avant d'avoir des
informations sur l'enquête dans un
instant puisque Sandra nous a donné les
infos sur l'enquête où on était
l'enquête moi je comprends pas comment
un mec comme ça il peut disparaître
excusez-moi Michel c'est quand même fou
au bout d'un mois on arrive pas à le
retrouver
quand on est en cavale bon il faut des
amis il faut de l'argent faut de
l'argent
son visage est connu en tout cas a
priori il a pas quitté le territoire ou
en tout cas pas la connaissance des
autorités judiciaires puisque il n'y a
pas de trace de passage frontières à son
nom sauf à imaginer qu'il a pris des
faux papiers sauf enfin imaginer qui est
passé en clandestin en tout cas a priori
officiellement il y a pas de trace de
temps pour s'organiser c'est un quelque
chose voilà donc il a dû s'organiser
très vite si c'est lui qui était au
volant ou s'il était avec quelqu'un qui
était au volant et qu'il était à côté
c'est compliqué et puis autre détail
quand même il a un physique qui ne passe
pas inaperçu il est archi connu c'est un
peu comme si vous vouliez disparaître à
mon avis vous avez pas aller loin non
moi non
non non non c'est vrai et donc c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui quels sont les
hypothèses Michel on va avoir des
nouvelles de l'enquête dans un instant
mais quels sont les hypothèses qui sont
avancés par les enquêteurs qu'est-ce
qu'il y a GG moi non mais je pense que
on peut évidemment envisager
quels sont les hypothèses
vous venez de me le soufflé
c'est une effectivement c'est une
hypothèse mais c'est penser un petit peu
à Gérald de Thomassin qui était un autre
acteur qui avait disparu alors qu'il
était dans un état psychologique très
très compliqué à cuiser d'un meurtre il
était d'ailleurs il avait été blanchi et
il allait au tribunal de Bourg-en-Bresse
ou je ne sais où dans ce coin là en tout
cas pour rencontrer le juge qu'il devait
lui donner un nom lieu et il a pris le
train on perd sa trace à Nantes et il a
disparu on l'a jamais revu
Marouane béréni je sais pas les
hypothèses c'est effectivement peut-être
un suicide pour d'autres raisons que le
corps forcément
des suicides
Gérald Thomassin jamais retrouvé son
corps non plus
à la police
allés ils n'ont pas trop justement où on
dit l'enquête un mois après on est
l'enquête Sandra vous a fait un petit
point la victime écoutez
dernière nouvelle on a aussi une
information qui était ouverte depuis 11
août et c'est une juge d'instruction qui
recherche de l'enquête désormais et à
part ça on est on sait rien on attend on
attend les investigations que les
preuves
monter oui il y a une information
judiciaire ouverte pour blessure
involontaire et délit de fuite et le
procureur est très strict il a demandé
aux enquêteurs le silence absolu donc il
y a pas une info qui filtre alors il y a
trois hypothèses effectivement la thèse
où il aurait mis fin à ses jours qui
n'est étayé par rien la fuite est perdue
en solitaire c'est à dire que il garde
la voiture 20 km plus loin il se rend
compte de ce qu'il a fait si c'est lui
et il fuit ou la contrainte ou la
contrainte qui serait que ils étaient
plusieurs à l'intérieur de la voiture et
que des complices ont fui avec lui pour
organiser une question parce que j'ai
pas réussi à avoir la réponse est-ce que
délit de fuite est spécifiquement
adressé à Merwan ou est-ce que c'est
juste un délit de fuite sous X non non
juste comme témoin
la justice ouvre une information
judiciaire pour se donner les moyens
d'enquêter dans ce cadre-là donc si elle
ouvre l'enquête pour des lits de fit
c'est parce qu'elle évidemment d'accord
regardez fait mais c'est pas enfin c'est
pas a priori contre lui c'est a priori
contre les faits mais il y a quelqu'un
qui a fui c'est ce qu'on appelle
Sandra c'est un témoignage exclusif vous
entendez ce soir donc la victime
présumée voilà de bah c'est la victime
cet accident c'est pas qui est coupable
encore voilà on sait pas qui est
l'auteur on sait pas on sait pas où on
dit l'enquête elle nous a confié ce
qu'elle dira à Marouane Bérénice il
était en face d'elle écoutez
sans lui demander de voir si dans son
regard il ne cesse de culpabilité
vraiment voir essayer de voir
l'expression de son visage de son regard
si
en fait
alors c'est vrai que c'est elle elle
part du principe c'est lui c'est pas lui
c'est pas sûr voilà on sait pas qui
conduisait la voiture s'il était à côté
s'il a c'est vrai que l'enquête on sait
pas où elle est en tout cas ce qu'on
sait ce qu'elle a été grièvement blessé
dans l'accident elle nous parle de ses
séquelles un mois quasiment jour pour
jour après l'accident
aujourd'hui j'ai toujours 8 courses
fracturé la clavicule toujours cassée et
le bassin fracturé
le poumon le poumon j'ai un épanchement
toujours au poumon et on va dire
l'hémorragie abdominale elle est
résorbée en réanimation c'est un gros
accident ah oui bien sûr c'est
miraculeux le choc est extrêmement
violent c'est un énorme 4x4 donc elle
aurait pu mourir c'est pour ça que je la
trouve exemplaire parce qu'elle n'a pas
de m elle veut savoir est-ce que des
témoins qui ont parlé qui ont été
identifiés je pense que la scène a été
filmée par la vidéo surveillance quand
on est devant une boîte de nuit
généralement devant les boîtes de nuit
il y a de la vidéo surveillance pour
d'autres raisons mais pour en revenir à
l'enquête si le jus d'instruction par
définition ne communique pas avec les
médias en revanche le procureur lui peut
le faire et s'il le fait pas c'est
capriya il a pas grand chose à nous
raconter
c'est souvent malheureusement comme ça
quand il se cache derrière le je ne
communiquerai pas sur cette affaire ça
veut dire qu'ils ont rien alors parce
que toute la scène a été captée par les
caméras de vidéosurveillance de la ville
donc forcément aujourd'hui les
enquêteurs même si les images sont pas
d'hyper bonne qualité ils arrivent à
voir qui est au volant de la voiture
forcément
combien
vous de la faire
ce mariage ou l'enfant avait été enlevé
pendant le mariage et
merci on a une vidéo surveillance où on
voit normal qui conduit on voit une
forme à côté de lui une forme blanche et
c'est impossible alors on sait que s'il
y a plusieurs personnes dans le véhicule
absolument ça c'est des choses qui
peuvent voir quand même avec les caméras
il y a pas de précision détaillées mais
effectivement
non pas dans le coffre mais je pense pas
là il pensait pas qu'il allait faire un
accident il est pas monter dans le
coffre
avec sa voiture
les enquêteurs savent mais ne veulent
pas dire s'il y a une personne ou
plusieurs personnes à l'intérieur du
véhicule il se
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]